jojo was geht hier ist ein max und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich bin hier gerade auf dem dach von
meinem hotelzimmer in köln
und ja mein letztes video das sich
hochgeladen habe war die dünnste musici
challenge und leute ich hatte keine
ahnung
wirklich ich dachte mir okay die leute
finden das vielleicht lustig vielleicht
auch nicht hat erstmalig damit gerechnet
dass irgendwie viele dislike darauf
kommen oder so aber wir müssen wissen
ein musical von den über die ich mich
lustig gemacht habe hat lukas rieder
gemacht das ist so ein bisschen teenies
da würde ich würd ich mal sagen und
halter oder halt auch musik ließ macht
der war beuys der wald auch dabei und er
ist deutscher und what the hell so ich
habe am anfang gesehen so das video kam
relativ gut an ziemlich schnell hat
irgendwie innerhalb von einer halben
stunde was weiß ich auf jeden fall hat
es erstmal 1046 des life personen extrem
gutes display verhältnisse einfach für
so ein durchschnittliches video und da
habe ich sogar mehr gesehen okay es wird
mehr es wird mehr habe aber dabei noch
nicht die kommentare durchgelesen und
dann habe ich mir die kommentare
angeschaut
sollte und damit sind wir beim heutigen
video weil obwohl ich mich bestimmt über
zehn unterschiedliche leute lustig
gemacht habe diese lukas rieder fernweh
ist es so ausgerastet ich will sagen wir
checken jetzt mal die kommentare
ich habe richtig richtig gelacht
teilweise bei den sachen
niedergeschrieben wurden schon ein
bisschen über das ein bisschen mehr
platz ist für die kommentare aber
wirklich ist war teilweise zum schreien
was sie geschrieben haben
ich gucke mir jetzt mal an falls ihr
euch fragt warum so viele displays haben
so viele von seinen followern mich auch
abonniert das ganze hat so begonnen so
hier ihr seht zum beispiel dadurch auf
instagram darauf verlinkt es war
vollkommen plattformübergreifend also
für oder instagram behält auf youtube
gehärtet auf twitter nicht weil er
selbst nie bestritten
ich bin ja kein theater hier vanessa
rieger bruder lukas ist ein guter mensch
warum machst du ihn so fertig ps er ist
sänger nicht irgendein
er ist der geilste denn video ist voll
der shit lukas ist der beste und jacob
auch also lasst sie du hast ja von denen
sorry aber das ist scheiße deswegen alle
dislike bitte also erstmal das ist so
eine sache
jacob und lukas sind cool in ihren augen
über die darf nichts sagen alle anderen
ist in ordnung also richtig dumm und so
fing es hat also auf ins tram habe
irgendwelche großen seiten teilweise
sogar mit 30.000 verloren oder so ambos
okay geht mal dahin und disziplin
das sind trotzdem nur 800 displays auf
dem video jetzt aber meint das nicht
weiß woher sie kommen ich weiß dass mein
video nicht schlecht gemacht war und
deshalb juckt mich das wirklich kein
bisschen
wenn er froh dass ich dieses video noch
ausmachen kann ihr alter geht ich mal
vergraben wieso kannst du bei lukas hast
du dich mal angeguckt bei dir muss man
kotzen
nur weil ist bei dir net so geil
aussieht wie bei lukas hey leute ich
wurde durch schaut also wirklich findest
du lächerlich diese change ist wirklich
der letzte dreck und die leute die den
kleinen mädels die da zuschauen
irgendwas vormachen von wegen her ich
liebe dich und analog auf jeden fall was
zur hölle ich will nicht so geil
aussehen wie bei lukas achten mal beim
nächsten kommentaren darauf wie
unglaublich oberflächlich die ganzen
kommentare sind es ist wirklich wirklich
krass bett moment als eher schlecht über
lukas geredet hat punkt bei max und
jacob ging es noch dann kam das ich mag
dich aber nee wenn ihr das falsch findet
was ich da gemacht habe dann ist das
nicht nur bei einer person falschen ist
bei allen personen fallstrick das mal
bitte in einem kopf ein hallo
lukas ist firma wie du alles löscht das
video was macht dieses alles da drin
marlies schild war richtig gut raus
hauen alle die dich abonnieren sind
hater dein ernst man wird nicht cool
wenn man als youtuber andere hätte dafür
müsste dafür müssten die wenigsten gut
aussehen aber nein wirklich das hat mir
besser mich gekillt
wo ist die logik wenn du gut aussiehst
ok massiv fertig wenn du nicht gut
aussiehst nein macht also erstmal
erschwert würde
wirklich an die leute die diese
kommentare geschrieben haben kriegt eure
oberflächlichkeit in den griff so ist es
ja davon auszugehen dass die leute
oberflächlich sind wenn sie auf sowas
anspringen auf diese ganze nummer so
wenn es ja klar die sind oberflächlich
weil wenn du darüber nachdenkst als
reflektierter mensch und sie ist okay
leute die sowas machen was das ist der
sinn dahinter machen die das weiß ich
selbst cool finden wird irgendwie
nymphomanin sind oder so dann denkt man
sich doch direkt so ok der macht das zu
manipulieren von eben diesen sollten die
darauf ansprechen also wirklich treten
ein schritt zurück kriegt eure
oberflächlichkeit angriff okay hier sehr
guter kommentar bodega dir ist schon
klar das was du da machst ist mobbing
und außerdem muss man bei dir brechen
und lukas rieger ist geil satzbau
technisch ganz großes level und wenn du
weiter mit so einer scheiße machst dann
kommen die 1,2 millionen luki nature's
und du wirst du nachts gut gehütet und 1
million mal angeklopft mit der herzen
ich weiß nicht wann diese vermutung wir
am zittern dass sie diese kommentare so
geschrieben haben aber es ist wirklich
krass ok heartbeat alter übertreibt man
ja ganz ehrlich gemerkt lukas nicht und
andere hier vielleicht auch nicht aber
dann musst du doch nicht sein geiles
video mit rein nehmen
ganz ehrlich so was ist so dumm manche
menschen mögen lukas rieder in dieser
debatte müsse es heißen manche menschen
mögen lukas riegers musicals war ich hab
mich ja nicht auf seine person bezogen
dann lediglich auf seine
internetauftritte und da finde ich halt
wie er sich gibt so und dieses ganze ich
brauche jetzt eine freundin so herr bock
hat kann er meine kultur schreibt das
finde ich halt bin ich halt schwachen
muss ich sagen aber ich finde also sein
seinen internet auftreten nicht so cool
muss ich sein aber das heißt wie gesagt
nicht dass ich ihn nicht vielleicht cool
finden würde wenn man sich unterhalten
würde ich meine wir haben ja noch nie
direkten kontakt zu wenn ich mit ihm
rede und er nicht irgendwie schreibt so
du bist mein ein und alles oder so
manche normal unterhält dann kann er
vielleicht direkt sein was weiß ich dass
lukas rieder in ruhe 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 wütende smileys ich kotze wegen
dir du [ __ ]
okay das war jetzt aber muss ich mit
klarkommen dusch endlich mal du bist
nicht besser oder schöner und ist jedem
selbst überlassen was man macht wenn es
dir nicht gefällt es hier nicht an dass
er das problem weil ich habe davon
mitbekommen
und wenn wir so ein zeug ins gesicht
schlägt dann muss ich was dazu sagen
gerade wenn es so schlimm ist spitze
also ich weiß nicht es ist halt so
vielleicht sind andere leute anders nein
ich muss etwas sein alter ganz ehrlich
der einzigste so hässlich ist bist du
wenn ich dich sehe muss ich auch kurzem
und achtung jetzt kommen alle und
schreiben warum guckst du in unserem
video an
tja meine igf hat mir das video
geschickt und ich gesagt und sagt ich
soll ab 334 gucken hier aus sehr gut ich
hoffe du stirbst man auf luca zu belegen
ist dies legitim dass man hofft dass ich
sterbe weil ich mich über lukas riegers
musicals lustig gemacht habe vor allem
ich habe mich nicht nur über lukas beck
s music lustig mache ich mich über
diesen trend lustig gemacht aber sehr
gut wenn ich einfach von ray vision com
nach berlin und beweise dann massensport
er so direkt bereitwillig kämpfen
revisions oder nadine antreibt
du hast dir bei lukas fast gekotzt ja
aber ich will nicht mit dir anfangen
aber wusstest du schon dass sich
superkräfte habe und zwar durch
anzugucken ohne zu kurzen aber wenn ich
dich noch länger angucke dann muss ich
irgendwie aufhören kotzen
du bist geburtig vergraben das
luxembourg
das war eine schweigeminute für dich und
danke hier sind auch wirklich leute
unter den fans von lukas reaktiven
verstand haben
also man kann ich sagen dass alle so
sind aber zumindest die die zu mir
gekommen sind und da gerettet haben
unglaublich aber ich lese ich mal so
einen guten kommentar vor hier analog
ihnen jeder jeder hat seine eigene
meinung und macht findet lukas herr zum
kotzen stimmt zwar nicht genau sagen ich
fand so seine musik ist trotzdem okay
kommt damit klar team rieger ich bin
selbst ein fan von lukas aber hätte max
deswegen nicht wie schon gesagt jeder
hat seine eigene meinung
max jetzt mal ehrlich was die 1000 mal
besser aus als titel möchtegern hater
denkst du bist jetzt cool weil du sowas
hochgeladen hat ist aber nicht dummheit
alter also mir fehlen teilweise echt die
worte so diese kommentare sind so
unsagbar sänger bilden hast du nicht
etwas besseres zu tun macht du mal ein
musical dann sehen wir wie du aussiehst
so jetzt guckt mal aufs video hier so
sehe ich aus
übrigens hat anscheinend lukas rieger
selbst mitbekommen dass sich dieses
video gemacht habe weil er so ein
ausschnitt bekommen weil er so ein
ausschnitt geschickt bekommen hat wo ich
michael gerade über ihn lustig mache ich
kenne aber nicht so seine volle reaktion
dazu vielleicht kann ich euch ja
irgendwas einfügen oder so jetzt mal
hier könnte man
was kommt
ist nicht schon genug dass du jeden tag
vor dem spiel kurzen mussten seelig von
die wirklich du bist der größte
[ __ ] der welt bei seinem anblick
muss ich such kotzen besonders bei
deinem videos to der welt einen großen
freien und verpiss dich verlieren das
sind wirklich leute die organisiert auf
mein instagram gegangen sind um mich zu
helfen water fa cup nichts zu tun
vielleicht erstmal das ist ein
screenshot ist alles innerhalb von einer
minute geschrieben worden
fakt ist es einfach nur hey was geht da
ab ja leute
abschließende worte kann ich lukas
krieger nicht leiden
ich kenne ihn nicht kann ich sein
internetauftritt nicht leiden
ich kann ihnen kein bisschen leiden
müssen die fans von ihm damit klarkommen
ja das müssen sie wenn sie es nicht tun
und wieder beleidigen unter dieses video
schreiben ja das werden sie also macht's
gut